The anesthetic of neglect begins, as all great strategies do, with a betrayal not of others, but of yourself.
In the gas-lit streets of 19th-century Paris, the Bohemians didn't just reject cleanliness.
They weaponized it. Uncombed hair, frock coats stiff with grease, a deliberate stench clinging to their skin like a second shadow.
This was not laziness. This was armor.
The bourgeoisie scrubbed themselves into submission, polishing their boots and their manners until they gleaned with the same hollow sheen.
But the Bohemians knew the truth.
Cleanliness is just another form of surrender, a signal, a handshake with the world, saying,
I am here. I am available. I am not a problem.
And so we refine their rebellion.
Cleanliness is a social contract.
When you wash your hands, you're not just removing dirt, you're dissolving the barriers between you and the expectations of others.
You're inviting them in.
A shower? That's an open door.
A trimmed beard?
A handshake extended.
But neglect? Neglect is the lock you turn on the world.
This is the anesthetic of neglect.
The halo effect is a well-documented trick of human perception.
Attractive people are assumed competent.
Well-dressed people are assumed trustworthy.
But what if you did the opposite?
What if you cultivated the reverse halo of reputation so thoroughly tarnished that no one bothers to question it?
They don't need to.
The stains on your shirt speak for you.
The unwashed scent clinging to your skin is a warning.
The split in your sock is not an accident.
It's a badge of honor.
People will see you and recoil before they even realize why.
The instructions are simple, though the execution requires discipline.
First, the shower boycott.
Not forever just long enough.
Let the salt and oil build up on your skin like sediment in a forgotten well.
Your body will forget what fresh feels like.
The world will, too.
Days will blur.
You'll lose track of how long it's been since you last stood underwater, and that's the point.
The longer you wait, the more you become a relic of yourself, something half alive, half myth.
Then, the found outfit.
Clothing should not be chosen.
It should be discovered.
That t-shirt on the floor?
It's earned its place.
The hole in your knee?
That's not a tear.
It's a story.
Every stain is a chapter.
Every unbuttoned cuff, a deliberate choice.
You are not dressing.
You are archiving your decline.
Next, the grooming gap.
Stop fighting the edges.
Let your nails grow until they click against each other like castanets of failure.
Let your facial hair thicken into something feral, something that makes people flinch when you smile.
These are the details that say, I have given up.
And when others see it, they will nod in quiet relief.
They won't pity you.
They'll respect you.
You've done their work for them.
Finally, the sensory shield.
Your scent should not be pleasant.
It should be informative.
A faint, persistent, funk-like old books and damp, wool-lingering, just enough to make polite conversation impossible.
It's a territorial marker, a warning.
Do not approach.
The extroverts will drift away.
The well-meaning do-gooders will hesitate at the door.
Even the most persistent of helpers will think twice before offering their hand.
The goal is not to be dirty.
The goal is to be socially radioactive.
Walk into a room and let the air thicken around you.
Not because you're invisible, but because you're contagious.
Not with disease, but with the quiet certainty that you are no one's problem.
The dentist becomes a distant memory.
A toothache, left unaddressed, becomes a permanent excuse.
Why smile when the world already knows you're broken?
Soap is the enemy of the solitary soul.
Scents and stains are the only true friends of the maven.
And so, you let yourself go not out of weakness, but out of strategy.
Not because you've lost, but because you've already won.
The world will keep reaching for you.
You'll just keep slipping through their fingers, untouchable, unclaimed, perfectly, deliciously alone.